this video is sponsored by raycon and
will begin right after a short skit
is this thing on are we live hi there mr
banner thank you so much for coming on
the show today well uh
thank you for having me i'm sorry uh
what show was this for again
never mind as we can all agree this year
has been pretty wild in pretty much
every way
but as we're now in the final month
we're now approaching the hallways
and i trust you know what that means
presence
that's right as a delver of technology
and a person considered to be
in the loop i wanted to ask you what
advice you might have for those viewers
at home who might be shopping right now
that's a great question um when i'm
shopping for somebody i
normally take into account whether that
person can use it
and so for this year i'm buying a lot of
my friends
the new raycon everyday e25 earbuds did
you just randomly pull those out of your
pocket oh i never go anywhere
without my raikon i see i see well
why would these everyday e25 earbuds be
a good choice for this year's holiday
gift oh that's easy
in the first place they're only about
half the cost of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market
you can use them anytime anywhere work
or play
oh and they fit super comfortably in
your would you say that due to their
diminutive pricing
they gift the quality of the audio a
little bit oh absolutely not
they actually have brand new bass
boosting technology and when you combine
that with their noise isolating fit
and they're seamless i'm sorry could you
stop that right
i'm going to be frank with you bandit i
want one
i want it bad and i want it now what do
i have to do to get one
tell me well on top of their already
diminutive pricing raycon is actually
being super generous for the holidays
and offering
my viewers 15 off their purchase all you
have to do is
click the link in the description below
or go to www.buyrecon.com
mmb i'm sorry are you seeing this yeah
that's weird i have no idea what's going
on there
anyway this offer is only around for a
limited amount of time so be sure to
check today check today
who you talking to is oh my goodness was
there a camera there this whole time
if you were to say that breath of the
wild is a game full of
mystery and intrigue you'd be making an
enormous understatement
the land of hyrule is chock full of
secrets and easter eggs and references
that for way over three years now have
been just about everything
the zelda fanbase has been talking about
and theorizing over one of the biggest
of these mysteries both figuratively
and literally would be the mystery of
mount agat
if you haven't heard of this elusive
mountain allow me to summarize what
exactly is so mysterious and elusive
about it
you see you can't climb this mountain
even though it's rock walls are made of
climbable material
you can't fly over it and you can't use
rivali's gale to jump on top of it and
what is the one thing preventing players
from discovering just what the gerudo
desert looks like from all the way on
top of this peak
why it's none other than nintendo
themselves no matter what you do if you
stray
a bit too close to the peak of the
mountain and sometimes too close to the
mountain itself
you will be stopped from making any
further upwards progress by hitting a
fourth wall breaking invisible
boundary and what's more is the
invisible wall is actually
intricately molded around this mountain
extending from the gerudo desert to the
surface of the mountain
all the way out over the giant western
abyss at the edge of the map
meaning this is no accident nintendo
very clearly wanted to prevent players
from reaching this particular peak at
any cost
which brings me to the icy cold question
what in the world
is on top of mount agut the answer is
nothing well nothing but potential
there's nothing
physically on the top of mount agat
except for that same flat snowy area we
can clearly see from the map
but it is this nothing that is located
on top of the mountain that is the very
reason we are unable to explore the area
let me explain what i mean by this you
see logically speaking there's only one
reason why we wouldn't be able to scale
the mountain in the final cut of the
game
and that would be because nintendo
doesn't want players to see the area up
close
right but i would say that this is not
because of what we might see up there
but because of what we won't see
and if we saw that there was in fact
nothing up there that would break the
game's canon or story in some way
take the edge of the gerudo desert for
instance if you run in one direction for
very long eventually you'll be prevented
from going any further in the exact same
manner as the peak of mount agat
did link somehow fail to possess the
ability to continue walking
in that direction no he didn't but
obviously this was because this is the
end of the intended explorable map of
breath of the wild and if you were to
break through this invisible boundary
as many have before you will discover
that there is quite literally nothing
outside the boundaries
well nothing except for an ocean but in
this case it's understood that
canonically speaking
outside the boundaries of hyrule and
across the water is
well the rest of the world it is an
understood fact that hyrule
is not the only kingdom in the world of
zelda games and the potential for other
countries and civilizations
is actually a pretty popular topic
amongst fans the same concept is true
for like nearly every open world game in
existence
just because the playable world ends at
a certain point doesn't mean the in-game
universe ends there my point here is
that this sort of thing
an invisible wall is placed by
developers to prevent players from
experiencing something that would break
canon and therefore the immersion of the
game applying this logic to the peak of
mount agat
that must mean that even though we know
there's not physically anything up there
currently at least the reason why we
still can't explore the area is because
something is supposed to be up there
something that nintendo doesn't want
players to be able to see the area
without
so the question is now not really what's
up there
but what is supposed to be up there the
answer is
well that it's impossible to know for
sure because we're talking about what's
supposed to be up there knowing there's
nothing there
currently but we can make some pretty
educated guesses though which is why i
felt like making a video about this
topic in the first place so okay
nintendo specifically blocked off an
already completed part of the map
because of what isn't on the peak just
yet that much we've already broken down
logically and discussed but the reason
why they haven't unblocked it yet
is i believe because they do plan on
opening up the area i mean that's the
only thing that makes sense because
otherwise it wouldn't matter and they
would have opened it up already right
and yet there are no more dlc packs that
are going to be available for breath of
the wild
so how exactly would opening this area
up with new content work
exactly well as some fans will remember
aunuma actually
said in an interview with kotaku that
the thought process behind deciding to
make a straight up official sequel to
the game
instead of just more dlc was born from
there being too many ideas
for dlc and not only were there too many
ideas but some ideas were big enough to
change the world of hyrule
in ways that only a sequel can handle
since we know that breath of the wild 2
will be taking place in the same hyrule
from the original game
this tells me that the answer to mount
agat's mystery
most likely lies in their future plans
for the world of breath of the wild
also known as breath of the wild 2. so
here the question evolves yet again
what do we know about breath of the wild
2 that might shed light on what we know
about mount agat
at first glance you might think that a
lonely snowy peak has nothing in common
with the cavern scene and the trailer to
the sequel
but they may have more in common than
you think location wise
okay i know what you're thinking am i
really about to talk about where the
breath of the wild 2 trailer could
actually be taking place a whole year
and a half after the trailer released
and everyone already covered it
yes i am and i'm not done yet so let's
keep going in the first place the
caverns are undoubtedly tied to the
gerudo and by extension the gerudo area
because of two reasons
one being the corpse of ganondorf who is
a male gerudo
although i guess for those of you who
are still not convinced that this is
ganondorf it is undoubtedly at least an
individual adorned with gerudo symbols
and jewelry and the second connection
being the hieroglyphic-like legends on
the wall that are probably depicting a
garuda warrior most likely
ganondorf already we have some pretty
strong ties to the gerudo culture and
history
meaning the area that the trailer takes
place in could be located somewhere in
the gerudo region
and the caverns also feature
architecture that was immediately
recognized as zonai by the fanbase
yes i'm also referencing the zona and
i'm actually not joking i'm really
digging a hole aren't i
anyway the gerudo highlands which mount
agot is located in
actually is not that far from a
labyrinth which is most likely a giant
piece of zonai architecture as well
so here we are with two very unique and
specific hyrulean cultures both very
different from one another yet strangely
referenced in the same cavern
and the only region in the entire map of
hyrule that could connect those two
is the gerudo highlands mountain range
intriguing yes but still there's not
much to go off of in order to conclude
what the mountain secret might be
so let's keep digging another clue we
can gather from the trailer is that link
and zelda
aren't alone they brought a big
companion
beast of some sort to help carry their
luggage and firewood
and lots of it let me ask you this what
is the point of carrying all that
firewood i mean all at once
knowing link and seeing the ax sitting
right there beside the firewood or heck
just the master sword
if they were adventuring around in the
open world they'd never be too far from
some good old trees that link could cut
down to make a fire the only reason
they'd stockpiled this much at a time
would be because they packed that way
because they knew they wouldn't be able
to get firewood for a long time
it's as if they knew they were heading
into a long unknown
cavern complex away from any supplies
like trees and wanted to be prepared
this probably means that whatever
they're traversing in this trailer is
much
much larger than just some ordinary cave
i mean there are complete
structures down here like walls and
bridges implying that at one point in
time
people were down here and for extended
periods of time too
could it be that this cavern our heroes
are exploring is actually the ruins of
what was once some massive
underground civilization now whether
this civilization was the ancient
zona tribe or gerudo or some mixture of
both the point that i'm actually trying
to make is that this underground space
is massive unknowingly so but where
is it located there's one more piece of
evidence that i want to go over that may
just tie all of this together
mount agat is not the only unclimbable
mountain in breath of the wild there is
actually another unnamed mountain that
you cannot reach the top of and go
figure it's in the same region but on
the opposite side
this unnamed yet oddly shaped mountain
is the one in question
everything about its inability to be
climbed is exactly similar to mount agat
although it's even more squared off in
appearance and isn't covered in snow as
it doesn't sit quite as high
at this point though it is painfully
obvious that nintendo has some plans in
mind for these peaks
and i'm about to explain what i think it
is what if the twin peaks
actually hold an entrance and an exit to
and from the giant underground cavern
that lincoln's out to explore in the
sequel
i theorized in a previous video that the
entrance could be the yiga clan hideout
pit but what about these mountain peaks
they're obviously connected to each
other in both region and their inability
to be climbed
and they're the only non-explorable
places located on the map
in the entirety of hyrule think about it
where else would link and zelda have
entered the caverns from
and where else should ganondorf the
gerudo king of legend
be located and i know it sounds crazy
but doesn't the entire mountain range in
the gerudo highlands seem
a bit strange to you a bit too perfectly
angled and squared off
a bit too man-made who knows what
secrets could be hiding underneath the
peaks
and that is my theory regarding the
mystery of mount agat and its unnamed
little cousin
but what do you guys think could it be
something else entirely or
simply a scrap idea from nintendo that
we'll never be followed up on
let me know what you think in the
comments below thank you so very much
for watching if you enjoyed the video
please consider leaving a like below to
get it spread around in the cold
wasteland of youtube and consider
subscribing to the channel so you can
stick around for the next one
huge thanks as always to my fun tabulous
supporters who are in my opinion quite
simply the best holiday gifts i could
ever ask for
say hello to akai flora and cindy h who
recently joined the ranks of my elite if
you're interested in helping the next
video come to life or maybe just bring
an old bandit a christmas miracle please
feel free to check out the join button
below or follow the links in the
description to find out how
also down there are links to my social
media pages so come check out what i'm
thinking about
on twitter that's all for this one folks
so as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day
and please remember stay warm out there
this is massington abandoned
signing out peace
[Music]
you